die ärzte sind in großer sorge um den
gesundheitszustand von queen elizabeth
die 96 jährige hat sich schon länger aus
der öffentlichkeit zurückgezogen und der
buckingham palast hat jetzt ein
offizielles statement abgegeben wir
sehen hier schon die bilder von schloss
balmoral
im offiziellen statement sagt der palast
nach einer untersuchung heute morgen
sind die ärzte der königin um den
gesundheitszustand ihrer majestät
besorgt und haben empfohlen dass sie
unter ärztlicher aufsicht bleibt ja die
96 jährige hat vor zwei tagen erst noch
die neue premier ministerin ließ zur
neuen premier ministerin von
großbritannien ernannt und sie ist jetzt
auch besorgt sie sagt das ganze land ist
in großer sorge um die königin und
normalerweise hätte die ernennung auch
im buckingham palast stattfinden sollen
aber die königin hat liszt was auf
schloss balmoral in schottland empfangen
wo sie schon eine zeit lang ist sie hat
sich in den letzten wochen und monaten
schon immer mehr aus der öffentlichkeit
heraus gezogen hier sehen wir die bilder
wie die königin lässt rus empfängt und
heute eben die nachricht das ist wohl
nicht gut um den gesundheitszustand der
queen steht und soeben erreicht uns auch
die nachricht dass prinz charles und
prinz william auf dem weg zu ihrer
mutter und großmutter sind nach
schottland hier sehen wir jetzt auch die
ankunft
die autos fahren vor hier sehen wir noch
mal jetzt lässt was wie sie ankommt auf
schloss balmoral
da sind die bilder von vor zwei tagen wo
die queen sie empfangen hat
und ja die königin hält sich
traditionell auf schloss balmoral von
mitte juli bis oktober auf genießt dort
normalerweise ein verlängerten sommer
urlaub aber nun diese schocknachricht
die ärzte bangen um den
gesundheitszustand der queen prinz
william und prinz charles sind auf dem
weg zur queen sind also keine guten
nachrichten die uns da heute aus
großbritannien erreichen
und wir schauen auf prinz william und
auf prinzessin kate heute ist nämlich
ein großer tag bei ihnen denn die
sprösslinge von william und kate die
gehen wieder zur schule und damit auch
wirklich nur das beste für george
schadet und louis beim schulanfang
geschieht hat die ganze familie schon
vor dem gebäude royale bildungs luft
geschnuppert und das war's jetzt
anschauen
es ist der grosse tag an dem thronfolger
aus dem königshaus genauso sind wie ihre
untertanen der erste schultag von den
royalen sprösslingen george eliot und
neues von william und kate hand in hand
vereint laufen wie mit ihren kindern zu
ihrer neuen schule die language school
die hier ist ganz in der nähe von ihrem
neuen zuhause dem adelaide cottage in
windsor hier in berg shire begutachtet
die familie schon mal den ort an dem
george eliot und louis zukünftig fleißig
und vom feinsten die bücher wälzen und
die meiste zeit verbringen werden eine
wahl ganz nach der tradition der
königlichen familie und das kostet auch
ordentlich für alle drei werden pro jahr
eine stolze summe von rund
85.000 euro fällig dafür können sich die
sprösslinge auch in extravaganten hobbys
austoben denn auf dem gelände gibt es
nicht nur eine schwimmhalle haben dann
sogar eine imkerei und wem das noch
nicht reicht kann sich an kohle oder
fechten wagen vor allem für den vier
jahre alten prinz louis auf muss die
aufregung groß sein der erste schultag
ist gleichzeitig seine einschulung aber
mit seinen geschwistern zeigte sich
schon ganz
zur erinnerung sousa damals die
einschulung von prince george und
prinzessin schalit im jahr 2017 aus na
dann kann der erste schultag heute doch
nur unvergesslich werden und vielleicht
gibt es für die drei sogar eine kleine
schultüte
die ärzte sind in großer sorge um den
gesundheitszustand von queen elizabeth
sie sehen hier im bild das ist schloss
balmoral in schottland wo die queen sich
aktuell auf hält die 96 jährige hat sich
ja schon länger aus der öffentlichkeit
zurückgezogen und der buckingham palast
hat ganz aktuell ein statement abgegeben
das heißt nach einer weiteren
untersuchung heute morgen sind die ärzte
der königin um den gesundheitszustand
ihrer majestät besorgt und haben
empfohlen dass sie unter ärztlicher
aufsicht bleibt hier sehen wir also das
statement des
buckingham-palastes große sorge also um
den gesundheitszustand der queen und
jetzt bei mir im studio unsere expertin
bettina von schimmelmann schön dass du
da bist hallo keine gute nachrichten
also aus großbritannien keine guten
nachrichten aber es ist auch nicht so
dass es total unerwartet ist also es
gibt natürlich schon seit
der crown geguckt als weiß es gibt viele
prozedere die jetzt die ganze zeit
hinter den kulissen ablaufen natürlich
wird dann im nächsten überlegt okay wen
informieren wir wann
und natürlich jetzt erst mal geht es um
die um ihre gesundheit ist das aller
aller wichtigste aber trotzdem muss
natürlich ja die krone weitergeführt
werden und deswegen heißt ja auch dass
william und kate schon bereits da sind
wir gucken auch gerade wo sind merken
und harry sind die eventuell vielleicht
auf dem rückweg nach kalifornien gewesen
sind sie vielleicht doch noch in london
und dann werden jetzt erstmal sich die
ganze familie um sich versammeln weil
das ist wie in jeder anderen familie
auch so natürlich möchte man in solchen
momenten die familie bei sich haben vor
zwei tagen haben wir die grünen noch
gesehen sie hat liszt was die neue
premierministerin empfang auf ihrem
schloss balmoral in schottland hat sie
dort so premierminister denn ernannt
normalerweise findet dieses prozedere im
buckingham palast statt diesmal war das
anders liest was ist nach schottland
gereist auch das völlig nachvollziehbar
die queen ist 96 jahre alt sie ist nicht
mehr sehr gut zu fuß das wussten wir
auch sie hat ja auch hier einen stock
und dass man dann natürlich sagt klar
ändern wir das ganze prozedere und
nochmal ist hinter den kulissen hinter
den palastmauern wissen sie natürlich
viel mehr als sie uns nach draußen hin
um damit wir keine sorge haben zeigen
wollen und wir sehen hier auch dass die
familie gerade anreist es ist ein
furchtbares wetter in innen in
schottland es ist also wirklich traurig
und was bei dem vor was bei dem foto
hier auffällt wo wir sie mit list straße
hin sie geht am stock sie hat noch ein
lächeln im gesicht aber die hand das
fällt ins auge die ist blau von der
königin die hand ist blau das könnte
verschiedene gründe haben es halt auch
heißt oftmals auch wenn man injektionen
bekommt das dann gerade bei älteren
leuten die hand sehr schnell blau also
das dann wird die haut wird und es heißt
ja auch dass sie doch verschiedene
medikamente bekommen hat in den letzten
wochen und ich kann mir gut vorstellen
dass die queen natürlich niemals ein
foto veröffentlichen wurde indem sie
irgendwas wie eben eine lektion in der
hand oder vielleicht sogar im
krankenbett das wird es niemals geben
dieses foto und deswegen gehe ich davon
aus dass ich auch nur für diesen event
etwas an also den schottenrock angezogen
hat und dem leser angezogen hat auch
etwas das er lautet was sie nicht sehr
aufträgt weil sie einfach nicht möchte
dass irgendjemand sie schwach sieht
prinz william und prinz charles sollen
auf dem weg zur queen seien auf dem weg
nach schloss balmoral nach schottland
bei der queen eben zu schauen um zu
sehen wie es ihr geht ja das ist ihre
aufgabe also es ist ja es noch prinz
charles er wird dann king charles werden
deswegen ist es ganz selbstverständlich
dass er da ist und wenn es ihr wirklich
richtig richtig schlecht geht und wir
glauben wir alle wir kennen unsere queen
als ja unverwundbar und jemand der immer
da ist und vor allem natürlich auch
immer alles im griff hat soll ich kann
mir gut vorstellen dass selbst in
solchen schweren momenten die queen noch
charles anweisungen gibt wenn sie es
denn kann und dass sie wirklich alle
beruhigen wird weil sie ist nicht jemand
der irgendwas laufen lässt oder der
möchte sich andere um sie sorgen
unser korrespondent an strickler ist uns
jetzt live zugeschaltet aus london und
was hast du für aktuelle informationen
rund um den gesundheitszustand der queen
für uns
guten tag ich habe aus dem palast noch
immer keine bestätigung davon gehört das
ist tatsächlich so ist wie alle
nachrichtenagenturen hier in
großbritannien mittlerweile melden dass
nämlich thronfolger prinz charles und
auch sein sohn prinz william auf dem weg
nach schottland sind wir gehen aber
davon aus das ist mittlerweile der fall
das deutet wirklich darauf hin dass es
der königin der 96 jährigen königin
nicht sonderlich gut geht sie hat ja wie
wir bereits berichtet haben ein online
meeting gestern abend überraschend
abgesagt mit dem neuen kabinettsminister
das hätte sie aus ihrem sessel in balve
hätte machen können hat sie abgesagt
meiner meinung nach ein ganz schlechtes
zeichen anzeichen dafür dass es ihr
wirklich nicht sonderlich gut geht und
heute mittag dann die hiobsbotschaft aus
dem buckingham palast der mitgeteilt hat
die königin sei in bar moll und der
ärztliche aufsicht gestellt worden der
buckingham-palast hält sich mit solchen
meldungen eigentlich immer ziemlich
zurück er weiß natürlich wie schnell
menschen sich sorgen machen um eine 96
jährige frau um königin elizabeth die
tatsache allein dass der buckingham
palast offiziell mittlerweile bestätigt
dass die königin und der ärztliche
aufsicht in balmoral ist deutet meiner
meinung nach darauf hin dass es ihr
wirklich schlecht geht die queen man
kennt sie als sehr sehr pflichtbewusst
und jetzt hat sie eben dann gestern wie
wir gerade gehört haben auch ein online
termin abgesagt bei uns im studio
begrüßen wir jetzt auch unsere bild
unterhaltungschefin tanja may dann ja
schön dass du da bist was hast du für
aktuelle informationen für uns ja im
prinzip auch nur das was bettina und ja
gerade schon erzählt haben aber ich kann
auch nur noch mal bestätigen also es ist
absolut selten dass der palast sich
äußert und wenn diese tatsache wie es
jetzt passiert ist ein community
veröffentlicht wird über den
gesundheitszustand der queen dann heißt
das sieht ernst aus ich habe auch
gänsehaut schon die ganze zeit weil ich
mir gar nicht vorstellen mag dass diese
frau stirbt aber natürlich wird es
passieren irgendwo aber irgendwie hat
jeder von uns ja gedacht das ist noch so
lange hin und dies mit 96 jahren
vermutlich unverwüstlich aber heute
jetzt muss ich sagen möchte ich auch
dass es ernst ist prinz william und
prinz charles sollen schon auf den weg
zu ihr seien auf dem weg nach schottland
zu schloss böhmer was heißt das ja
leider auch nichts gutes fürchte ich
auch dass ein weiteres zeichen wie ernst
es stehen muss um die königin also wenn
prinz charles und sein sohn sich auf den
weg machen auch dass ein weiteres
zeichen es geht ihr nicht gut und wir
haben sie als erst gesehen gestern und
vorgestern sie hat ja noch die neue
premierministerin ihres landes hat sie
ja noch einen empfang genommen und man
hat gesehen sie hatte ganz blaue hände
das hatte prinz philip auch zum schluss
also bevor ihr mann gestorben ist hatte
der auch diese blauen hände und da
gibt's natürlich verschiedene
erklärungen wir haben ja auch mit ärzten
gesprochen das kann durch bluetooth
durchblutungsstörungen sein können
infusionen seien also es gibt
verschiedene informationen woher diese
blauen hände kommen aber ich habe
gestern als ich diese fotos gesehen habe
von ihr und wie klein sie ist wie zart
und dieses schmale köpfchen hat man
gestern schon geahnt dass es ihr nicht
gut geht und man kann wirklich zu gucken
wie sie immer kleiner und wie sie immer
weniger wird dieses foto gerade mal für
48 stunden aufgenommen wo sie lässt rast
zu neuen premierministerin er nennt sie
hat ein lächeln im gesicht die queen ist
nicht zurecht gemacht hat ein cover rock
trägt sie hier aber sie geht auch am
stock und hat eben diese blaue hand sie
sieht aus als er gerade wenn wir uns
dieses foto angucken sie sieht aus wie
eine kleine zarte porzellanpuppe also
man sieht ja sie hat noch mehr
abgenommen jetzt in den letzten wochen
und auch ihr gesicht ich finde daran
sieht man eben dieses ganz schmale
gesicht ja sie wird immer weniger aber
sie hat den termin ja noch wahrgenommen
vor zwei tagen sie wollte list raßloff
treffen hat gesagt sie soll nach
schottland kommt zu ihr auf schloss
balmoral normalerweise findet termin der
termin ja im buckingham palast statt
aber das war eben ein anliegen den
termin noch durchzuführen es war für sie
ein sehr sehr wichtiges anliegen das ist
auch immer ein sehr entscheidender
moment wenn der neue premierminister
premier ministerin kommt und die queen
ist so jemand die ihr ganzes leben lang
genau geplant hat was sage ich der
öffentlichkeit wie zeige ich mich in der
öffentlichkeit was veröffentlichen wir
wie waren ich kann mir sogar fast gut
vorstellen das klingt jetzt total
emotional dass sie vielleicht gesagt hat
wenn dann ist das vielleicht mein
letztes bild aber ich möchte eben dass
jeder mich aufrecht stehen so gut ich
eben kann in einem schottischen rock in
einem offiziellen anlass sieht
und die green hat ja erst vor einigen
monaten ihren mann verloren ihren
geliebten prinz philip und jetzt kommt
eben diese nachricht das ist der queen
nicht gut geht und dass ihre familie
jetzt auf das beim dorthin reist nach
schottland um sie zu besuchen
das ist richtig
wir müssen daran denken dass prinz
william ja heute gerade seine kinder
zur einschulung gebracht hat das heißt
für die camps familie ist das ein ganz
ganz wichtiger tag die tatsache dass
prinz william kind und kegel in winzer
zurücklässt um mit seinem vater nach
schottland zu fliegen um seine
großmutter zu sehen deutet meiner
meinung nach ganz eindeutig darauf hin
dass das nicht wieder einer dieser na
wir haben es in den letzten jahren öfter
mal gehabt es gar stories wie die
engländer sagen eines dieser zither
geschichten ist die königin hat einen
kleinen wussten und die ganze welt sorgt
sich ich glaube das ist in einer anderen
liga mittlerweile was wären die
nachrichten die wir aus schottland
erhalten es bedeutet meiner meinung nach
alles darauf hin dass mit der königin
wirklich nicht gut geht und wir können
einfach nur das tun was die ganze welt
derzeit tut wir können einfach nur
abwarten zu sehen ob der palast weitere
nachrichten über den gesundheitszustand
der königin rausgibt eines wir können
uns so ein bisschen damit trösten dass
die königin in den besten medizinischen
händen ist in denen man sein kann die
höhe königlichen hof ärzte sind alles
sehr sehr lang auf
gute mediziner internisten dabei
orthopäden und so weiter also wir können
zumindest sicher sein dass sich die
königin im moment dass die kämpfer titel
ist also dass sie sich dass sie sich
dass sie nicht leidet er
interessanterweise ich hab mir grad
nochmal das statement des bat ihren
palast des angebots dass unsere wenigen
minuten erreichte da heißt es die
königin sei
sei sie leider nicht es käme so der
palast das deutet darauf hin dass sie
wirklich in guten sicheren ärztlichen
händen ist und wir können einfach nur
abwarten wie ich schon gesagt habe was
die nächsten stunden bringen werden
jedenfalls kann man sagen heute
nachmittag england und ich gehe weiter
und sage die welt hält den atem an
[Musik]